good afternoon
my name is Dr Elizabeth libach and I'm
very pleased to be with you today
um to speak with you about
uses for Clinical Laboratory informatics
and decision decision support uh the
primary mechanism for adding value in
healthcare delivery from the laboratory
standpoint uh today
um
excuse me for for the delay I'm looking
at all my controls this is a very
exciting uh Endeavor for me for this
this webinar and I wanted to tell you
too before we uh get too much further
into the presentation that I am in
Augusta Georgia and the weather is
beautiful however we have been having
some fun shows in the afternoon so
hopefully days won't interfere with our
broadcast today
um
uh I also wanted to mention before I go
I've made a couple of notes here that
um we will be uh having questions and
answers for the last 15 minutes or so of
our session today
um and so if you would uh make notes of
those and uh submit them and then we
will discuss them at the end of the um
presentation and also I had several
things that I was supposed to remember
to do one of them was to talk to you
about the um the question and answer
session but the other one was to add a
slide on how you can obtain continue
education credit for this Symposium this
webinar uh if you are so interested the
session has been approved by the aacc
for their CMEs and
um there is a website that you should go
to for uh application for the good
credit and let me read it to you because
I forgot to put it in my last slide so
that website is
www.bioconference live all one word
um.com forward slash CME Dash CE so
again the website is
www.bioconferencelive.com
forward slash CME slash CE
so thank you very much and um I also
wanted to tell you that uh today we're
going to talk a lot about
um
evidence-based practice in laboratory
medicine or laboratory medicine uh
evidence-based practice
and uh specifically
the theory surrounding that and sort of
describing for you a whole research
agenda for the laboratory medicine
Community related to clinical
Diagnostics and to convince you that in
fact informatics is a pivotal piece to
our analytics capability going forward
in this endeavor
so toward that end then
um
our objectives for today's session are
to Define evidence-based practice in
Clinical Laboratory science
to summarize the evidence-based practice
connections among critical thinking
quality improvement patient safety and
expert practice and also to describe the
relationship of evidence-based practice
to practice skills specifically
informatics required in today's
Healthcare delivery system
okay
the evolution of evidence-based practice
really uh parallels the the evolution of
of quality and Quality Systems
development
um
so beginning the uh discussion of
evidence-based practice and informatic
support of evidence-based practice uh
should be should begin with the
discussion of quality so I have a uh on
this ladder picture from you of a
Laboratory
um uh in the beginning of the quality
control days in laboratory medicine and
I I want you to know that this is not a
picture from
um some dusty archive somewhere it is
actually a picture of the first lab that
I worked in as a medical technologist
so it really is uh not that long ago but
as as we can see as we will see as we go
through the slide there have been a lot
of changes and I think clearly you'll
see the evolution of um our quality
practices back in the beginning of uh
our quality methods in the laboratory uh
Circa
1960 laboratory quality uh was centered
around a menu of about 60 tests that
were all manual in their methodology the
quality was specifically defined as
quality control
patient safety related to direct patient
care only
and payment was for it was fee for
service
and capital expenditures were passed
through to
Health Care financing
at the federal level nine laboratory
Physicians made diagnostic decisions and
what I mean by that is that literally if
a physician wanted a test then the order
was made and the test was done there
were no questions about relevancy or uh
efficiency medical Effectiveness and
even
not even efficacy that often in terms of
assistively and specificity but remind
I'll remind you that we only had a menu
of 60 paths quality now in laboratory
medicine
is quite different we have a test menu
of approximately 10 000 tests and with
molecular our
molecular test menu growing it we add
tests virtually every day
quality includes quality control
measures but also incorporates concepts
of quality improvement and total systems
quality of which our quality improvement
and quality control efforts are apart
and we'll have a few slides that talk
more about that
capitation is very common in terms of
reimbursement and today
non-lavatorians make diagnostic
decisions just like they did in the old
days but
um
the non-labatorians are not necessarily
uh non-uh they are not necessarily
Physicians but in US often they are what
we commonly call
um uh
mid-level practitioners
so the
bottom line is our interpretation of
quality for these other Health Care
Health Care practitioners is even more
critical than it ever has been
so in summary uh the slide that that you
see now is
uh sort of summarizing the
interconnections of quality control
quality assurance and quality
improvement
um Quality Control uh are it is control
on basic analytic processes and the CLIA
recommended an individual quality
control program is based on level of
risk acceptable for each of these
processes I'm going to persuade you
later
um hopefully at the end of the session
you will be persuaded that in fact uh
for our risk assessment in clear
recommended uh iqcp programs we should
actually include we should consider
Health outcomes as well and we'll talk
about evidence-based practice methods as
being the way to incorporate these
Health outcomes into our processes of
quality
while the Assurance fan of performance
measures that come from quality control
and identified and monitored attract
over time while the Improvement being
analytic QC process data from all QA
studies that are then evaluated as a
group and uh improved as a group
this slide is a my way of kind of
showing how each of our analytic units
in the laboratory fits into the broader
um
the broader Total Quality Management
plan of a system
in a total quality management or
continuing process Improvement program
processes are cross-cutting throughout
the Enterprise improvements rely on
evaluation of each of the individual
units that contribute measures to them
and analytic feeders are organized at
the system level system level
performance measures are complex and
meaningful in all analytic units that's
a requirement
then for uh quality improvement at the
individual level our processes that are
uh are concomitant with the total system
Total Quality Management Programs our
plan do check act
um lean which includes just income
measures of inventory
most of these are related to cost
efficiency Endeavors in terms of quality
and Six Sigma as well
improvements in these areas impact
system level performance measures and
its measures chosen from these studies
that then will feed into the larger
Total Quality Management measures at the
systems level
sort of a game changer in our
measurements of quality in the
laboratory uh occurred
in at the turn of the century in 1999 a
groundbreaking record-breaking report
from The Institute of medicine was
um was announced
and this this
report
um
documented a large number of patient
deaths and and that resulted as a a
function of of eras medical eras so that
uh a new set of patient safety aims were
recommended and have pretty much driven
uh efforts in quality improvement in
health care since that time those aims
are safety efficiency timeliness Equity
Equity Effectiveness and
patient-centered care all of these aims
collectively are moving our health care
delivery system toward one that is
value-based and not volume based as it
as it was in the
um
old days in the beginning of our quality
measurements back in the 60s
so from this point in the presentation
we will talk about uh
basically how to move from this volume
based Healthcare delivery system to a
value-based healthcare delivery system
in specifically terms of laboratory
medicine and what that means for our
operations and how we actually
look at quality
the
method I propose to you today that is
the method that will get us there in
that transition from volume base to
value-based healthcare delivery for our
laboratory Community is an
evidence-based approach this is the core
idea of of evidence-based approach in
medicine in general and laboratory
medicine in specific
first the core idea is that our
practices in fact should be based on
evidence and effectiveness
the problem with this is that practice
as we know it today is not always
supported by evidence from Clinical
Research in instead uh we often practice
because we've always done it that way
and because it's efficient for us not
necessarily that uh Health outcomes are
improved or even
um Downstream costs for our institution
are improved
the solution then is to determine what
is that in fact effective through
evidence-based evaluations of our
practice so that in a nice compact
definition evidence-based laboratory
medicine is the conscientious explicit
and judicious use of the best evidence
from Clinical Laboratory information in
making decisions about the care of
individual patients
so
evidence-based lab evidence-based
practice for medical laboratory
practitioners then
um
incorporate skills and we'll talk a lot
more about this that we've never really
developed in our past practice
in our
iterations of quality that rely on
instrument evaluation those are
statistical evaluations that uh that
really
um are based on instrument performance
which we have down very well in terms of
our quality for our instrumentation
but evidence-based practice in the
broader sense particularly related to
patient-centered care
depends on looking at quality measures
in the analytic phase two focus should
be on accurate and precise measurements
there
and also assessment of medical orders as
well as specimen collection storage
transportation and accessions
then also on the post analytic phase
consideration of interpretation
communication and utility in clinical
decision support all of that is part of
evidence-based practice and builds on of
course the analytic phase
let's take a common uh as an example
let's take a common uh quality measure
for The Clinical Laboratory and that is
hemolysis rights
um
hemolysis can occur if blood samples are
improperly collected this we know that
hemolysis then can result in testing
eras in Sample rejection and those
actions of
testing areas and single rejection then
can cause retesting that results in
patient
delays in treatment or sometimes
inappropriate interventions in there uh
in their care and treatment so
pre-analytic bias can lead to errors in
analytics which can then lead to patient
safety dangers so this is an example of
a measuring the laboratory that is
cross-cutting across other areas of our
institutions
and in healthcare facilities
and requires studies that bridge other
delivery services within a hospital and
requires the participation and
collaboration of others other health
care providers in
um in reducing the rates of analysis or
improving these measurement parameters
the potential of evidence-based practice
is that quality is increased in health
care the products are increased in
quality the processes the performance
that maximize value for all consumers
are the quality of all these areas are
increased the operation the
evidence-based practice pretends to
operationalize quality services delivery
in All Phases of the diagnostic testing
process
so that actually our practice will be
data driven rather than expert driven
and our results then can be used with
confidence in medical decision making
the availability of defined consistent
clinical research designs in methodology
with potential for generalizing and
benchmarking uh will will be available
uh so that our quality improvement
programs will not just be internally
utilized but we'll be able to share them
among the laboratory community so that
all practices the best practices will be
standardized within the community
then our best practices
link
uh practitioner clinical research their
competencies and their education so
um uh from from the beginning of the uh
of the career path for the medical
laboratory professional uh these best
practices and the research that
um that should be conducted in order to
Define best practices should be taught
from the very beginning and we should
also then include other health care
practitioners on the other end in in
establishing and implementing these
death practices that we have discovered
through our clinical research
in fact evidence-based profits is based
on clinical research and through through
this clinical research quality
improvement efforts in in our
Total Quality uh
Improvement programs are in fact linked
to clinical research and I might just
add here that because of that and the
um the linkage of our patient data to
that informatics becomes critical in
documenting patient consent and RB
approval for these clinical studies
the slide that you have before us
before you now is actually a method that
for for
evidence-based practice research and
quality
that is called the A6 systematic review
method
on the right hand side of your screen is
the method for uh the sticks the six
steps of the method that are include or
Incorporated in the systematic review
process from which best practices are
gleaned and reported on the left hand
side of your screen though is a
modification of the six step method that
can be followed for implementation of
these best practices and for then
iterative
evaluation of the results of these
practices so quickly I would like to
just
identify for you out loud
um
the six steps so the six steps are ask
acquire a praise analyze apply and audit
and assess
at the ask step then
is pivotal
and is the first really critical it has
to be addressed critically in the
beginning of the process and what is the
formation of the clinical question what
is it that what is the problem in
healthcare delivery what is the problem
in delivery of left or services that
needs to be addressed so here at this
level then all sorts of other methods
that are commonly used in the laboratory
can contribute to the honing of a
a precise clinical question like
um uh the the plan do check at the root
cause analysis uh steps that we we uh
are
very familiar with the laboratory can be
used to actually Define a clinical
question
then the step that is added in the Asics
method that you usually don't find in
typical quality improvement studies is a
review of the literature for the
systematic review process that second
step requires a huge exhaustive review
of literature for the application step
or excuse me being quiet step in them
in the implementation side on the left
the process for doing to our studies uh
the literature review does not have to
be that detailed but you'd be looking in
the literature to identify studies that
that would that have been uh
published as being solutions to the
problems that you're looking for and
like that you're looking at in your
Institution the next step is to appraise
and that is to set the size the results
of these this literature review and
create an evidence-based base and then
decide which uh best practice in the
literature is the one that fits your
process in in your in in your protocol
in your facility the best
apply is then to uh in uh to implement
the intervention in your
facility
and to then audit assess is the last
step and that is to evaluate the results
of your study to see where further
Improvement should uh be considered of
course this is an iterative process and
a cycle in its nature therefore the name
uh the A6 method or the A6 cycle
I I want to depart a little bit from a
direct discussion of all the six steps
of the Asics cycle wall but we will talk
about those in a few minutes to say that
um
that important for us in laboratory
medicine is an understanding that our
work our clinical research that we're
about to discuss in terms of
evidence-based practice and clinical
outcomes and and medical effectiveness
of our Laboratory Testing
relates to the broader literature or
related to health services delivery
these
aspects of Health Services delivery are
education Theory social theory access
Theory organizational systems theory
economic theories and ear theories of
isomorphic pressures that that drive
decision making ends in in individual
clinical facilities like pneumatic
coercive and normative forces that we'll
Define in subsequent slides all of these
though come down to the Clinical
Laboratory through the prism if you
would of quality Theory and that is
through knowledge translation and the
quality framework that was given us by
Don obedient who did so much good work
in quality in Health Services delivery
yeah
and then in specific you can see the
next to the lifestyle is the A6 method
so the A6 method I propose to you is
actually the methodology to evaluate
these different hypotheses or clinical
research questions that come up through
our work and Health Services delivery so
evidence-based practice actually
um that whole construct for us has put
us into the area of Health Services
delivery research and we should be
examining these clinical questions
through that broader literature and
Reporting those our findings in the
broader literature
so that being said I want to say also
that evidence-based practice has roots
in learning theory and this is a slide
that I've included for you because I
think it's just uh has well really it's
because it's jam-packed with information
not only
um
uh is it kind of fun to look at but it
is uh very instructional but I'm not
going to uh
to go into every aspect of the slide
that can be for homework for you
um but suffice it to say that there is
critical thinking theory that relates to
higher order processes of thinking and
uh skills that we employ in
evidence-based practice that then
allow us to accumulate the knowledge
that we transfer through our
evidence-based
methods to things like Six Sigma and
Asics method and
patient centered care and I help
Services Research and and
clinical research in the laboratory
educators are very interested in how to
um how to construct learning and
transfer situations that would mimic the
uh the authentic practice role in
evidence-based practice and all of this
relates to research that they are doing
in the um go back in the area of
critical thinking and knowledge transfer
and it's really fascinating
so in sort of summary then of all the
theory business uh down at the bottom of
this slide uh we see that Asics method
is the quality framework linking
clinical outcomes in the laboratory
to patient safety indicators
and informatics Analytics
so then
um in on the left hand side of the
bottom you see our quality control
efforts that then feed into the Asic
cycle uh into the total quality
management system in our institutions
then we see that outside pressure
suggests treatment algorithms in patient
safety targets uh competitive forces uh
impact how we view our laboratory uh
diagnostic information
regulation of course
certainly has an effect on how we view
our laboratory uh data and what we
choose to do in terms of our test offer
in terms of our test menu Etc and then
of course best practices that we
Benchmark among ourselves also
um
impact uh how we do our business as a um
as a community in laboratory medicine
then each individual health care
practitioner has a base of
evidence-based practice
and this translates knowledge to Total
Quality Management operations as well
and feedback feeds back to us as to how
we should improve the information that
we provide to these other practitioners
so it's a very complicated system all
those pieces as well
uh should be actively researched by
Laboratories
what are some implementation strategies
then for evidence-based practice well
first
you need to identify informatics and
Analysis capabilities
we have a great opportunity today with
the electronic health record to actually
begin to
evaluate Health outcomes and health
indicators help help measures patient
outcome measures
evaluate and correlate
our laboratory inflammation relative to
those Health outcomes like we've never
been able to do before going through a
patient record uh of paper patient
record is prohibitive in terms of
acquiring all the measures the
indicators that you would need to have
to be able to to Really measure the
medical effectiveness of of our
Laboratory Testing however with the
Advent of the electronic health record
this is becoming a possibility however
currently uh
we are struggling with standardization
of language and nomenclature uh four of
these these measures
um in addition our laboratory database
is not often relational to the point
that we can correlate our test values
with
um
demographics and Diagnostics or rather
diagnosis information of our patient
database so those two databases often
don't
um speak to each other
but going forward uh in this talk the
Assumption will be that that those
informatics capabilities will be
available to you for setting up these uh
these clinical investigations that have
become a part of laboratory quality
then we need also to determine
opportunities for high impact
interventions and I might say here
because I'm going to talk a little bit
more about this too that our whole basis
of quality is is evolving uh from a
quality control and quality process
monitoring as we see with our
statistical quality control
um and uh and our lean Sigma studies to
one that is based on risk
what the A6 method allows us to do and
we'll talk more about this in subsequent
slides is to bring in health outcomes
into that risk assessment mix and we'll
we'll hopefully by the end of the talk
convince you that in your quality
improvement studies going forward that
they are not complete uh unless you
build in measures of medical
Effectiveness into those quality
improvement studies
we need to identify performance measures
of course and then search the medical
literature for applicable comparative
effectiveness and outcome studies as
well as best practices and practice
guidelines
before I'll leave that slide I might
make a Shameless plug for
um a a website that is is um maintained
by the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention that actually catalogs best
practices in laboratory medicine I have
a link for it or uh information on the
on the the URL in the last slide which
is a list of
um
uh preferences for you for additional
Reading Please I urge you to go visit
that the laboratory medicine or uh best
practices website which is called
futurelabmedicine.org
and look at the best practices that have
been cataloged so far and read more
about the
evidence-based love medicine effort that
is underway at CDC
in terms of
deciding which quality improvement
process is most imperative to address
first in other words deciding on the
clinical question that would uh is the
basis of the answer to the question of
the problem that is occurring in your
laboratory that you would like to
research a good way to do this would be
to employ A variation of the Pareto rule
which is to look at
diagnoses in in your
um in your operation that either have
the highest
has caused or the highest volume or
carry the highest risk in terms of total
resources
and then
um
we'll actually go through and exercise
with uh
with determining this but once uh once
you've decided then which
diagnosis you should examine first then
we can start uh accumulating the
information that we need in terms of
that step to Second Step in the Pro in
the Asics process we need to look at the
informatics that are available and the
use of informatics Information
Technology because undoubtedly this is
where the performance measures
are going to come from
search the literature for best practices
and then uh
design a clinical study to address the
question
what we have found in
searching the literature for Best
Practices is that
um
though a lot of analytics are reported
in terms of test efficacy sensitivity
species and predictive value
there are limited numbers of
publications related to Medical
Effectiveness and best practices in
terms of test algorithms for addressing
uh specific diagnoses
then often even when we find these these
uh Publications on medical effectiveness
the studies are conducted in such a way
that
um
that conclusions definite conclusions
can't be drawn that can be benchmarked
to other institutions so the this is
kind of typical of quality improvement
studies uh in the past
because the results of those quality
improvement studies were never meant to
be generalized they were they were meant
to be utilized to improve processes
within a specific institution so this
slide is uh important is a a listing of
important study
components that should be considered
carefully when you conduct or when you
design a quality improvement study and
then of course later when you implement
it
in the design side uh Define a
measurable question first of all uh and
formulate hypotheses
carefully Define the population you'll
be looking at and carefully just
describe the setting
and describe the study period all three
of these areas uh if if not carefully
controlled or carefully described and
carefully understood from the researcher
standpoint
can add bias to the results of a study
so certainly in reporting these studies
uh one should elaborate
thoroughly on uh the population the
setting and the study period of that
that was important that were
incorporated into the study design
the intervention practice should be
carefully uh described as well as the
the Baseline
process to which the the comparator or
the intervention is will be compared
then of course in terms of outcomes not
only should current laboratory
traditional outcomes be measured but
also Health outcomes and patient
outcomes should be monitored as well so
identify and Define outcomes and
measures that relate to health outcomes
and then describe carefully the
appropriate analytic methods and
expected results so when we think of
anal or in informatics we think of I
think usually
in my opinion we think usually of the
electronic health record and a sort of a
transcription of a of a paper kind of
process but I maintain for you today
that uh in integral in that should be
um the analytics capability because
that's really what we need in order to
be able to uh to perform evidence-based
practice in laboratory medicine
so we need to know then
um a lot of skills related to
statistics and particularly Data Mining
and statistics related to Big Data as as
uh the term is used today
the slide that you have before you now
is a consultation logic model that I
propose is a way of determining with
data
in a data-driven evidence-based way
which
um
uh
methods in which problems in the lab you
should be addressing
if if you actually document the the
consultations that come into the lab uh
making sure that you uh document
what medical topic is being discussed
and what medical service the
consultation is coming from then an
analysis of this would give you uh alvia
of the diagnosis that a priority for you
um to consider in working up the
problems that are presented to the
clinical lab
this is a slide that is an example of
the analytic frame related to the
hemolysis problem the of sample
rejection due to analysis that we
discussed before this was actually a
best practice review that uh that was
done at this at the CDC and the
interventions that were looked at were
um are listed in the center of the slide
the recommended pharmacist review the
recommended practice to best address the
rejection of Saint Paul's due to
analysis is to act actually Implement a
phlebotomy team
um uh and and to not draw through an IV
set but to do a a single needle draw
um not through an IB set and those two
practices uh were
um the best at preventing sample
rejection due to hemolysis
I'm watching my time here and uh want to
spend a little bit of time on the side
that you see before you now which is a
um a slide that is a composite of the
Asics method and three different studies
that were that were implemented using
the A6 method
so uh these are Qi study examples that
link pre-analytic and analytic test
phases through the A6 method
the question that was asked if you'll
look at the um bottom of the arrow
the the three questions that were asked
in three different studies the first
question
um
uh well let me back up a little bit
um and say that these these uh problems
were identified through uh through
indicators that are commonly measured in
quality control efforts in the
laboratory uh we found that there were
turnaround time issues related to three
processes and those processes were
sample rejection and mislabel specimens
and blood culture contamination so
studies were then um
uh designed to address each one of those
issues and why we were seeing increased
sample rejection and increased mislipal
specimens and increased blood culture
contamination
so current if you look at
um number four analyze current
practices were evaluated and pre and
post uh designs were implemented so that
the our quality measures were were
measured after the interventions were
implemented
the implement the uh interventions were
for the specimen rejection
that there were no IV draws so with uh
um
with implementing uh a single needle
draw situation
um
we found that in fact
I'm having a little uh problem with my
um computer here bear with me
we found that um
the rate of homeostasis or rejection due
to analysis went way down
then with the Miss label specimens we
found that the best practice was
barcoding that barcoding in some cases
completely eliminated the uh
mislevel specimen issue
problem and then with the blood cells
contamination implementation of a
phlebotomy team that was well trained uh
in electronic cultural collections
greatly decreased the number of
contaminated literatures that were uh
found in the laboratory
foreign
excuse me a minute again let me see now
I'm back oh good good
this slide I I inserted into the slide
deck to
um to remind you to keep this process in
mind as you are employing informatics
analytics in your Qi studies in the uh
incorporation of Health outcomes into
these these studies
the high tech act it ushered in uh
an era
of information exchange that
um
has just begun
all of this is being uh either our EHR
products are being standardized through
mist or uh through the
um the office of the national
coordinator in terms of the EHR uh uh
development so in this process I urge
you to uh you have there are options and
ways for you to have a voice and uh you
need to pay attention to what's
happening at the national level with the
informatics
um analytics development and make sure
that we have the capability of actually
connecting our laboratory data to the
EHR data and then to population level
data uh going forward for the ability to
really be able to um to make the most of
our clinical informatics
just winding up then I talk I wanted to
leave you some some points to remember
first of all uh in terms of uh mimic
mimetic pressures that are uh
that are
kind of forming the laboratory
communities uh
progress going forward we are competing
we are competing on value these days not
on
um Adam's items Nano now our extensive
menus but
we're finding that reimbursement favors
over utilization and looking at Medical
Effectiveness is a way to determine what
value our Clinical Laboratory tests
really are adding to Health Services
delivery and in the future this is the
way we'll be paid based on this value so
we need we need to know what value we're
bringing to the Health Care system we
need to organize horizontally as a
laboratory community so we need to
conduct these studies on quality and we
need to Benchmark them and communicate
and publish
we also need to encourage knowledge
translation through informatics so we
need to develop informatics programs
related to the laboratory uh we don't
need to rely on
um computer scientists or informaticians
to do this we need to become Laboratory
implementations
in terms of cohesive pressure we know
that
um
that reimbursement and regulation is a
driver in our community we need to do
real class analysis and
transition planning and we need to pay
attention to what's developing in the
regulations uh and we need to
re-engineer all of our processes related
to Quality our reimbursement our
reiterate is going to be value-based not
fee for service and going forward
our body of knowledge is crucial we need
to be communicating that knowledge uh
and uh not only to our practitioners our
own practitioners but to other
Healthcare practitioners as well they
are looking to us for guidance in their
medical decision making and we need to
we need to know what our value is in
that Arena wisdom is key we need to
integrate I.T we need to critically
think we need to pay attention to our
knowledge translation our vision and
succession planning
how can you get involved as leaders of
the laboratory increase the rigor of uqi
projects create a culture for clinical
research and disseminate findings in the
technical Workforce participate in qi
and tqm activities use the Asics method
for conducting quality improvement
studies as an educator introduce CT and
evidence-based practice methods and to
your students early on and encourage
their projects and students use the
Asics methods in your your quality
improvement process and learn clinical
research methods methodology and design
and also uh collaborate
I'll read you with this one last slide
which is dilberg and Bill Burt uh is
there talking to Wally says Wally I
decided uh or uh while he says uh
gilbertsons Wally I've decided to
um move your project due date up a month
so Gilbert says well every time it looks
like I'll reach an objective
you move it what does this prove about
my performance
Gilbert says it proves I'm better at
setting objectives that you than you are
at achieving them so the bottom line
here is don't get comfortable just when
you think you have all the answers all
the questions change
here is a list of additional reading if
you'd like to explore the evidence-based
practice movement more and you should
have handouts as well that are available
to you I'm going to move now for a few
minutes of um q a and I'll say too that
uh that if if we if if we have questions
that can't be covered in our time that I
will be glad to have you email me or
email leverage and then they can send
the emails to me and I'll answer them
via email and also you can remember
download your um handouts and I think
there might not be so many formatting
problems with them too
so there's a question here
having been a program a programmer and
an HMO working with both health records
and data warehousing where do you
include all right just a minute
where do you include the necessary step
of validating data value mapping
cleanliness and using different
relational database models in the
aggregate
uh I think I I think that this is a a
very detailed question about
uh really
validating the exchange of information
between the laboratory database and the
uh health record database
um
I I uh
I think that as currently the uh
electronic health record is not
considered the medical device but in the
laboratory Community we uh we have our
blood bank systems our transportation
medicine systems are considered medical
devices and with that uh requirement uh
or with that categorization there's a
requirement for a data validation and I
I definitely think that
um as we go forward in the development
of these databases that these sorts of
clinical research projects related to
standardization of nomenclature and
validation of data
data warehousing all of those things
need to be considered clinical research
projects and need to be
conducted
I I think they'll need to be conducted
by our
um lavatory
our laboratory Information Systems
vendors as well as the electronic health
record vendors and I I don't think that
a lot of those studies are currently
being done
um models for those kinds of efforts
though exist in the big commercial
databases
um and even the uh CMS databases in
terms of defining data elements there is
an iterated process that occurs there so
that perhaps our if our vendors were
willing
they could actually incorporate a
process like occurs in our commercial
databases
our Commercial Insurance databases to
validate and standardize the data
elements that will be of course the
foundation for data warehousing
so now uh that that is a laboratorium
sort of
um
view of of what needs to be done
in an informatics world uh an HMO
actually
is a very good opportunity for
um standardizing some of these processes
and Reporting those it it would be a
great boom to the laboratory Community
if in your position
in an HMO as an uh in informatics
if if these processes and
standardizations and language issues
data element definitions uh could be
benchmarked and published I think that
would go a long way towards helping us
standardize the uh the community and and
Payson our availability our availability
to the informatics that we need to
really do appropriate medical
Effectiveness and evidence-based
practice
foreign
so I I'm looking at my broadcasting time
and I think that's uh probably as much
time as I have so I'll close now and
thank you very very much for your
attention and be looking forward to any
questions that you have via email uh
don't forget your CEUs are available at
uh
www.bioconferencelive.com forward slash
CME slash CE thank you very much
bye-bye